[Music]
one of the top chefs from pasta palace
has been kidnapped by operatives from
burger Bazaar hoping to learn the
location of their secret sauce recipe
little do they know that a third party
sausage saloon has sent you to take
advantage of the situation as their top
spy your skills range from infiltration
and subterfuge to safe cracking and
reading faces for signs of deception
you've tracked the captors to where
they're holding the chef's prisoner from
your hiding spot you can see him on the
other side of the glass while in front
of you an interrogator wearing
headphones speaks into a microphone we
already know the recipe is on the
thirteenth floor of the bank vault in a
safe deposit box numbered between 13 and
1300 now tell us is the number less than
500 you can't hear the chef's answer but
you can see that he's lying
the interrogator however falls for it he
follows up by asking is it a perfect
square again you can't hear the answer
but can tell the chef is lying
while the interrogator takes him at his
word he then asks is it a perfect cube
this time the chef answers truthfully
the interrogator thinks for a minute and
says good now if you just tell me
whether or not the numbers second digit
is a 1 we'll be done here but as the
chef starts to answer the interrogator
stands up blocking your view within
moments he rushes out of the room
announcing that he's got the answer and
is sending agents to retrieve the recipe
you know that the burger Bazaar people
have the wrong box number but can you
figure out the right one and retrieve
the recipe yourself
the key here is to work backwards we
don't know what the chef answers to the
final question or whether he answers
truthfully but we do know that by the
time the interrogator asks it he's
narrowed the options down to two numbers
one where the second digit is one and
one where it isn't our goal then is to
find answers to the previous questions
that lead to just two possibilities of
the three constraints offered the one
that narrows our options the most is if
the number is a perfect cube that leaves
us with only eight answers between 13
and 1,300 so let's assume the answer to
the third question was a truthful yes
now let's look at the second question if
the chef answered yes to the number
being a perfect square it would narrow
the interrogators options to just 64 and
729 the only numbers in our range that
are both a square and a cube but neither
of these has a 1 as the second digit so
the given answer to the second question
must have been no and that also means we
can eliminate these two squares from the
interrogators list leaving only 6
numbers now for the first question which
allows us to divide this list if the
chef answered yes to the number being
less than 500 we'd have four options
which is too many but a no leaves us
with two numbers greater than 500 one of
which does have a 1 as its second digit
we don't know which of these numbers the
interrogator thinks is correct but that
doesn't matter remember his conclusion
was based on lies you on the other hand
are now in a position to reconstruct the
truth first the chef said the number was
greater than 500 but lied meaning it's
actually less than 500 second the chef
said it wasn't a perfect square but lied
again meaning the number is indeed a
square and finally he truthfully
confirmed that it was also a cube and as
we've already seen the only number under
500 that's both a square
and a cube is 64 you find the secret
recipe and are gone before anyone's the
wiser corporate espionage is not an easy
game but sometimes that's just how the
sausage is made
don't take a break just yet
the world needs you an evil syndicate is
primed to use its powerful death ray
use your espionage skills to infiltrate
their secret lair and save us all
[Music]